- When it comes to donuts,
I don't care if I'm betraying my country.
(funky music)
- I grew up with Tim Hortons.
Canadian, it's a point of pride for us.
- Tim Hortons I think is the worst thing.
I'm partial to Dunkin' Donuts.
- I don't get this Dunkin' Donuts hype.
- I think Dunkin' Donuts
is gonna be better.
- I think Tim Hortons is far superior.
- I don't like Dunkin' Donuts.
- I have low expectations for both.
- [Voiceover] These are
the original glazed donuts.
- Pretty good, pretty light.
- Not very fluffy.
I'm more of a mushy donut man.
- It seems like more of
a bagel than a donut.
- I knew it!
- Dunkin' Donuts.
- Yeah, Dunkin' Donuts!
- I thought it was going to be that, too.
- Tim Hortons, this is gross!
- Le croissant! Should
be better in Canada.
- Whoa.
- It's like, meh.
- This one doesn't really have a flavor.
- This one's better. I like that.
- Got a pretty rich cracker vibe about it.
- I would rather eat
this one for breakfast.
- Dunkin' Donuts again!
- Yes!
- No!
I've been hating on
Dunkin' Donuts forever.
- I do not run on Dunkin'.
Stop it right now.
- Yeah!
- I vote this one. Oh, man.
- [Voiceover] These are
the chocolate donut holes.
- Dunkin' Donuts calls them Munchkins
and Tim Hortons calls them Timbits.
- Classic war, the Timbits
versus the Munchkins.
- They look almost identical.
- Oh, yeah.
I can eat that all goddamn day.
- Not super flavorful, kind of bland.
- That one tastes salty.
- I like this one better.
- Dammit!
- Oh, okay.
- I have to get out of here.
It's just...
I'm sorry, I can't fucking...
- Wow!
- Yeah!
- [ Voiceover] These are the non-decaf,
original blend coffees.
- So this is kind of scary for me,
because I've been talking
crap about Tim Hortons coffee.
- I don't normally have
coffee after the morning,
so either way, anyone
want to party tonight?
- Smells like absolutely nothing.
- This coffee somehow tastes racist.
This one is much better.
It has like a richness to it.
- That's really mild.
- It's like, when do you
ever get a cup of coffee
and you're like, it tastes nice, but weak?
- Fuck that's hot.
That was so hot!
That one did taste better, though.
- They're both kind of terrible.
This one tastes more like a cardboard box,
this one tastes more like,
like one of those Airhead bottles
that's been left in the sun.
- If I have to choose one,
I'm gonna choose this one.
- No!
- Ah, okay, all right,
you came back in the fourth quarter
to win me over, Tim Hortons.
- I guess I've lived down
in America for a long time.
- Ah, fuck.
♫ Oh Canada ♫
- Tim Hortons, you got some
good freaking coffee, though.
Like, this shit's legit.
- Dunkin' Donuts, you're doing a good job.
You guys should, like,
open more stores in LA.
- Tim Hortons all the way.
- You know, we can't go
around just hating on donuts
because of national
affiliation and whatnot.
Sometimes you have to, like, try it
and maybe you'll surprise yourself.
(funky music)